In biology, transcription is the
process of copying DNA into RNA by an
enzyme called RNA polymerase.
Generally, RNA polymerase only wants to
transcribe regions of DNA called genes,
as these provide the correct
instructions for making useful RNA.
However, the human genome is 3.2
billion base pairs long, and only a
small percentage of it contains genes.
So how does RNA polymerase know where
to transcribe?
It makes use of what are called
promoters.
Promoters are DNA sequences at the
beginning of genes that provide a
landing pad for RNA polymerase and a
bunch of other proteins that
all together work to initiate the
transcription process.
In other words, a promoter both marks
the start of the gene and helps bring
it in for activation.
Although promoters for different genes
aren't exactly the same, they do share
some common features. For instance, a
good fraction of promoters contain what
is called the TATA box, a sequence
characterized by alternating adenines
and thymines.
This region of the promoter is
recognized by a protein that plays a
role in stabilizing RNA polymerase and
encouraging its activity.
In addition to the promoter, some genes
make use of enhancer sequences. These
are short sequences that recruit
so-called activator proteins that help
RNA polymerase work much more
efficiently.
Fascinatingly, enhancers are often
located thousands of base pairs away,
and so the DNA must loop around to
allow for enhancers to get close to the
promoter.
Overall, by using enhancers and
promoters as genetic signals, the
transcription machinery within any
given cell is able to appropriately
express its genes.